la séance est reprise la parole est au
président requier pour une mise au point
de vote
merci monsieur le Président la mise au
point concerne scrutin numéro 270
portant sur les amendements de
suppression de l'article 11 de la
proposition de loi pour une école de
liberté de l'égalité des chances de
laïcité Nathalie Delattre souhaiter
voter contre et Jean-Pierre corbiset
souhaitait voter pour
monsieur Levy ensuite
oui monsieur le Président je souhaite
apporter une rectification de vote sur
le scrutin numéro 269 sur l'article 1er
de la proposition de loi pour une école
de la liberté et d'égalité des chances
et de la laïcité madame Daphné rachmann
doux a voté pour elle souhaitait voter
contre et sur le scrutin numéro 271 sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi pour
une école de la liberté d'égalité des
chances et de laïcité madame Daphné
rakmadou a voté pour souhaiter votre et
Madame Brigitte devezat a voté pour
souhaiter voter contre je vous remercie
très bien et enfin Monsieur Manonville
c'est maintenant
dans l'analyse politique décrita en
cause l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
d'actualité sur le thème impact
économique social et politique de
l'intelligence artificielle générative
dans ce débat le gouvernement aura de la
faculté si le juge nécessaire de prendre
la parole immédiatement après chaque
correcteur pour une durée de 2 minutes
l'orateur disposera à son tour du droit
de répartie pour une minute le temps de
réponse du gouvernement à l'issue est
limité à 5 minutes monsieur le ministre
vous pourrez donc si vous le souhaitez
répondre après chaque orateur une fois
que celui-ci aura retrouvé sa place dans
le débat la parole est d'abord à
Monsieur entrée catalogue pour le groupe
RDPI pour 6 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier le groupe pudique
qui a initié ce débat qui un débat
particulièrement important et c'est à
moi qui les choix d'ouvrir le bal sans
introduction préalable sur un sujet
aussi complexe que celui de
l'intelligence artificielle générative
on devrait dire d'ailleurs les
intelligences artificielles génératives
puisqu'il en existe plusieurs types en
réalité il s'agit d'un sous-ensemble de
ce qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage profond qui est lui-même
sous-ensemble de ce qu'on appelle dans
l'intelligence artificielle
l'apprentissage machine il est basé sur
des systèmes neuronaux artificiels
concept qui était créé par des
universités américaines dans les années
40 mais qui n'ont trouvé réellement
d'applications concrète et de déboucher
avec le développement des capacités de
calcul et de stockage de données
uniquement ces dernières années un sujet
hautement compliqué parce que expliquer
ce qu'est un système neurolal artificiel
n'est pas chose simple l'idée c'est de
copier le modèle de fonctionnement du
cerveau humain pour prendre un exemple
quand votre œil enregistre une donnée il
transfère ses données à travers le nerf
optique au cerveau qui va bien sûr les
analyser vous êtes au petit matin vous
êtes pas très réveillé vous avez une
discussion générale à écrire et vous
voulez vous en presser de prendre du
café et l'image que le cerveau va
envoyer à votre plutôt que l'oeil va
envoyer à votre cerveau c'est celle de
votre cuisine et de la porte du placard
qui est ouverte naturellement vous savez
que après un premier traitement que
l'État se situe à un certain étage et
que par chance vous avez vidé le
lave-vaisselle donc vous êtes à peu près
sûr des trouver
la tasse de café évidemment vous vous
avez aussi soudain une mémoire d'alerte
qui vous rappelle que la dernière fois
vous avez fait ça vous vous êtes pris la
porte du placard dans le visage donc le
cerveau va faire un traitement complexe
pas simplement à partir des données
basiques qui ont été transmises
visuelles par le néoptique mais va le
réintégrer dans un IV dans un
environnement de Synaps et de neurones
qui vont vous donner aussi un certain
nombre d'éléments plus complexes qui
vont vous permettre de vous guider et
trouver la fameuse tasse pour verser
votre café ce système est
particulièrement riche et performant il
permet effectivement contenu des progrès
que nous avons aujourd'hui en matière
d'algorithme et la particularité de ces
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
générative c'est de ne pas reposer sur
un simple algorithme mais par un système
souvent complexe d'algorithmes qui
échangent entre eux pour vous donner une
information qui peut être utilisée alors
je disais je vais vous passer les
détails sur les différents types
d'intelligence artificielle
itérative il y en a qu'on qualifie
d'adversorielle puisque on met en
concurrence deux systèmes de réseaux
neuronaux qui vont s'enrichir les uns
les autres se transmettre des
informations pour
renforcer la qualité d'autres posent sur
des approches probabilités avec
d'ailleurs un niveau de détails et de
compréhension de la formation qui sont
plus élevés en tous les cas cela
signifie aujourd'hui une véritable
révolution sur le plan de la production
de contenu d'image et aussi de processus
de décision alors j'ai essayé je me suis
dit après tout ce matin j'étais pas très
réveillé je vais demander à une
intelligence artificielle de me préparer
mon discours en introduisant les données
que nous avons là impact économique
social et politique de l'intelligence
artificielle générative
le résultat est sympathique mais il est
extrêmement plat extrêmement descriptif
il dit pas des choses totalement fausses
sauf que il est incapable vraiment de
m'évaluer ou de supposer des impacts
économiques sociétaux et politiques ce
qui montre que la marge de manœuvre en
terme d'intelligence et de production
est encore particulièrement élevée je
croise cependant qu'il faut tenir compte
que des conséquences sont importantes et
j'ai eu la chance avec quelques
collègues dont Catherine Morin de
saillie et
mon collègue mon collègue qui va poser
voilà j'ai oublié son nom excusez-moi
c'est vraiment de l'intelligence Cyril
pelvin merci excuse-moi Cyril de de
travailler très récemment sur la la
proposition de règlement de l'Union
européenne en matière d'intelligence
artificielle alors là on est dans un
sous-ensemble comme je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure nous avons retenu deux
idées c'est que 1 et ça je le maintiens
par rapport à l'intelligence
artificielle générative c'est que un il
faut préserver les libertés les
responsabilités et l'éthique avoir une
éthique européenne de l'intelligence
artificielle et il faut aussi permettre
son développement en termes d'innovation
alors nous sommes tous affolés ces
temps-ci parce que nous avons vu le
succès de chat gepetti qui crée en
novembre de l'an passé en deux mois à
temps plus de 100 millions de
téléchargements c'est un record absolu
le précédent était retenu était tenu par
Tik Tok qui avait atteint le million de
100 millions de téléchargements en neuf
mois donc un succès incroyable qui
transforme par exemple dans le domaine
de l'éducation la matière la manière
d'anciennier la manière aussi de valider
les travaux il faut dire que le
numérique n'est pas quelque chose
d'uniquement négatif il faut voir ces
aspects positifs et notamment dans le
monde universitaire grâce au logiciel de
contrôle du plagiat nous avons éradiqué
cette vieille tendance alors le danger
avec l'intelligence artificielle nous
n'avons pas la contrepartie qui nous
permettrait d'en faire autant pour
autant je crois et en ouverture de ce
débat que nous devons peser bien sûr les
risques et les dangers ils existent nous
les personnes vont pas tous mais il y a
aussi des opportunités et une manière
d'utiliser ce nouvel instrument je vous
remercie merci chers
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je voudrais
saluer l'initiative prise par le Sénat
de ce débat d'actualité sur l'impact
économique social et politique de
l'intelligence artificielle et puis
saluer l'introduction qu'on a faite si
l'on peut dire André gatola à l'instant
qui a pu
témoigner de son expertise de sur le
sujet et saluer au passage évidemment le
rapport qu'il vient de déposer avec
certains de ses collègues sur cette
question
maintenant la parole est à Monsieur
Christian Redon Sarah dit autant pour
moi pour le groupe socialiste écoluste
et républicains et 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'intelligence artificielle générative
une technologie capable de créer de
nouveaux contenus écrits ou images
Russell un fort potentiel et ses impacts
sociaux sont multiples dans le champ
économique à l'intelligence artificielle
générative en permettant
l'automatisation de certaines tâches
répétitives et sans grande valeur
ajoutée accroît l'efficacité du travail
et donc sa rentabilité en créant de
nouveaux produits ou services basés sur
cette technologie et les potentiellement
créatrice d'emploi mais toutes ces
potentialités peuvent néanmoins
disruptives pour notre modèle économique
actuel
en général on risque de destruction
d'emplois ou en limitant la nécessité
d'acquérir de nouveaux savoirs
l'intelligence artificielle générative
obligera plusieurs secteurs industriels
à s'adapter pour demeurer compétitifs
des risques politiques et éthiques
existent aussi pour nos valeurs
démocratiques notamment par la
génération de faux contenus qu'il soit
écrit visuel ou sonore qui viendrait
nourrir propagande diverses et des
informations
les répercussions sur les processus
électoraux sont possibles à mesure que
les intelligences artificielles
génératives se perfectionneront il
deviendra de plus en plus difficile de
distinguer le vrai du faux
ce que vous venez d'entendre chers
collègues ce n'est pas un discours
rédigé exclusivement par mes soins ou
ceux de ma collaboratrice ce début
d'intervention a été généré après de 95%
par l'application tchat jpti monsieur le
ministre vous aviez qualifié
de perroquet à proximatif utilisé dans
un contexte d'une intervention dans
l'hémicycle le trouvez-vous convaincant
ou conservez-vous votre jugement
distinguer du vrai du faux création
d'emplois et potentielle disruptif en
une minute je pense que vous avez pu
relever les principaux apports et
risques de l'intelligence artificielle
générative limite et promesses dont la
machine elle-même semble parfaitement
consciente voyez vous voyez également la
nécessité qui est la nôtre de les
identifier pour combler le vide
juridique qui entoure le développement
de cette technologie dont on ne peut
nier le potentiel de fascination et qui
évolue à une vitesse sidérante comme
toute innovation majeure dans l'histoire
de l'humanité les intelligences
artificielles génératives font planer le
spectre de destruction d'emplois de
remplacement de la force humaine par
l'agilité de la machine d'une forme de
simplification de l'organisation du
travail la suppression du facteur humain
on oublie souvent de dire que les
nouvelles technologies quelles qu'elles
soient
créent souvent davantage d'emploi qui
n'ont détruisent par ailleurs leur
développement ne signifie pas
systématiquement abandon des
savoir-faire
l'intelligence artificielle peut donc au
contraire permettre la crise à Sion et
l'acquisition de nouvelles compétences
le secteur qui bien sûr sera le plus
directement impacté par son
développement sera sans doute celui de
l'informatique cela induira
nécessairement une adaptation et par la
même une expertise plus poussée de la
part des ingénieurs ainsi que la
création de nouveaux métiers attractifs
une des principales craintes
généralement partagée face à un tel
potentiel est aussi de voir l'humain
dépassé par sa créature toutefois cette
source d'intelligence demeure encore et
toujours l'humain tandis que les
intelligences artificielles génératives
ne demeure en tout cas à ce jour en 2023
que des fabriques d'illusion
en dépit de leurs qualités le contenu
proposé ne se base que sur des
corrélations statistiques un volume de
données certes exponentielle
exponentielle mais toujours limité et
sans l'humain pour l'instant point de
machines ces inventions posent néanmoins
de réelles questions éthiques et
philosophiques comme toutes les
technologies qui les ont précédé comme
Internet d'ailleurs elles sont un
pharmacon à la fois poison et remèdes
selon que l'usage que l'on en fait bien
sûr qu'entre le mauvaise main ces outils
sont dangereux parce qu'ils sont
hautement capables de tromper notre
vigilance et d'être utilisé pour
défendre des intérêts particuliers mais
cette créature nous nous échappera pas
si nous ne posons ne nous échappera que
si nous nous
posons pas les bonnes questions pardon
et si nous n'anticipons pas ces effets
pervers les mêmes interrogations
relatives à la régulation aux normes à
une éventuelle gouvernance mondiale se
pose aujourd'hui pour l'intelligence
artificielle comme elle se sont posées
depuis plus de 25 ans face à l'essor
d'Internet forcer de constater que nous
avons appris en marchant il pouvait
difficilement en être autrement faute de
précédent
mais nous disposons aujourd'hui de cette
expérience d'un corpus de réflexion de
normes d'une jurisprudence qui peuvent
toujours dit nous guider il faut nous
servir de ce savoir empirique une
difficulté demeure cependant face à une
technologie par nature dynamique qui
progresse sans cesse le risque de
caducité rapide d'énormes définies à un
moment précis et réel il nous faut donc
être plus rapide que la machine et cela
je pense où se situe le plus positif de
cette technologie innovatrice en nous
débarrassant du superflu elle peut aussi
nous permettre de nous concentrer sur
l'essentiel en vérité elle nous lance un
défi elle nous invite à un regain
d'intelligence si l'intelligence
artificielle générative peut nous
affranchir de certaines tâches
répétitives doit-elle fatalement nous
rendre intellectuellement paresseux
c'est à l'humain de montrer qu'aucune
machine ne peut surpasser son
intelligence son jugement son esprit
critique et sa remarquable capacité
d'adaptation qu'il soit positif ou
négatif les impacts sociaux et
économiques de l'intelligence
artificielle générative doivent être
adressées et ne pourront faire
l'économie d'une réflexion éthique afin
qu'elle puisse être utilisées au
bénéfice de l'intérêt général et cette
conclusion mes chers collègues elle m'a
été proposée par l'application
shadgipiti je vous laisse apprécier sa
pertinence
merci chers collègues
et maintenant parole est à Monsieur
Pascal symbole d'Élie pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le ministre
le Président mes chers collègues la
révolution numérique a impulsé un
véritable bouleversement du monde du
travail opérant une transformation en
profondeur de notre modèle économique et
les métiers qui ont constituent
l'architecture il estimé qu'environ la
moitié des métiers que les jeunes
écoliers d'aujourd'hui exerceront demain
des existent pas encore si les
potentialités de ce capitalisme digital
sont présentés comme assurément immense
cette digitalisation du monde alimente
la crainte d'une déshumanisation de la
société et d'une robotisation
généralisée dans l'orientation qu'elle
prend la prise nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un système où l'utilisateur est
poussé par l'ensemble de plateformes et
systèmes algorithmique à générer
toujours plus de données au service
finalement d'annonceurs de publicitaires
et de producteurs d'intelligence
artificielle valoriser dans ce Big Data
c'est gigantesque masse de données
numériques sont exploitées pour produire
les algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle ce système mes chers
collègues c'est celui de
l'intensification de l'exploitation et
de l'aliénation des travailleurs
j'en appelle pour preuve l'investigation
du journal Times qui révélait comment
l'entreprise open hey emploi des
travailleurs kedian rémunira moins de 2
dollars de l'heure pour indexer
d'immenses quantités de compte plus
toxiques circulant sur Internet afin de
nettoyer les données d'entraînement de
chat GPT
parce que le mal nommé un objet c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde comme disait
qu'avu il conviendra rappeler que
l'intelligence hardycle
n'est ni artificielle et ni intelligente
considérer le logiciel tchat GPT comme
intelligent s'estomper lourdement sur la
nature de notre débat en matière
d'enjeux écologique politique et sociaux
chaque GPT n'est pas simplement un
automate computationnel il implique
l'exploitation de ressources minérales
les terres rares et humaines nécessaires
à sa production et à son fonctionnement
il s'agit du travail gratuit de millions
d'utilisateurs dont les requêtes
améliorent l'algorithme ces micro-taches
rémunérés à moins de 2 euros de l'heure
s'affranchissant du salariat et
précarisant à l'heure actuelle des
centaines de millions de milliers de
personnes à travers le monde selon les
travaux d'Antonio casilli comme toute
révolution technologique la révolution
numérique est au coeur dans
l'affrontement de classe avec une
industrie du numérique qui n'a que seule
obsession que de casser le coût du
travail en espérant substituer du
capital mort au capital vivant pourtant
cette révolution numérique pourrait
créer de nouveaux métiers augmenter le
besoin en formation sinistre initiale et
professionnelle offrir la possibilité de
diminuer le temps de travail pour gagner
du temps libre néanmoins l'orientation
choisie par l'industrie du numérique en
collaboration aveugle de nos gouvernants
et manifeste il s'agit davantage
d'exercer une pression sur les salaires
sur l'emploi en captant la valeur plutôt
que d'améliorer l'efficacité sociale du
travail il s'agit de transformer en
plateformes nos services publics et
administratifs créant de facto davantage
d'insécurité sociale cette industrie est
dominée à l'exception de la Chine par
une poignée de firmes américaines
concentrant des capitalisations
boursières démesurées et motivé par une
visée politique mondiale
celle d'un capitalisme à son paroxysme
où l'on peut s'interroger de certaines
prérogatives étatiques en toute impunité
face à cela la France et l'Union
européenne ont joué le jeu des big tech
en relaquant le choix de l'outil
numérique ou d'un prestataire technique
à une logique utilitariste sans prendre
en compte les aspects politiques et
stratégiques il est impératif de
reprendre la main sur notre destin et
choisir la société dans laquelle nous
voulons vivre demain nous devons nous
réapproprier collectivement nos données
sous forme de communs en exigeant la
transparence et la lisibilité des
algorithmesmployés dans les algorithmes
participant à l'apprentissage
automatique cet espoir de transition
dans le numérique je le place aussi dans
notre jeunesse dans ce nombre
considérable de jeunes adultes qui ne
supportent plus de faire des jobs à la
con entendez ici chers collègues un
travail dont nous ne le trouve pas de
sens qui prive d'une réelle protection
sociale et qui propose une hiérarchie
autre que celle de la compétence parmi
ces jeunes nombreux sont ceux qui
veulent créer entreprendre pas forcément
créer une start-up et revendre au plus
offrant pour faire fortune mais dont
l'objectif est d'entretenir de rendre
accessible via un réseau numérique des
communs mondiaux d'innovation partagée
cette jeunesse pense nouveau mode de
production elle pense coopérative elle
pense économie sociale et solidaire
économie circulaire lutte contre
l'obscension l'obsolescence programmée
mise en commun ces nouveautés
au monde numérique capitalistique tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui on les retrouve
dans des ateliers coopératifs de
fabrication et de création numérique au
sein des communautés de développement de
logiciels libres mais aussi dans les
plateformes numériques coopératives ces
tiers-lieux préfigurent une possible
République des communs oui chers
collègues il est vrai cette révolution
numérique à Love depuis déjà des années
nous met au pied du mur du dépassement
de la considération salariale mais
aujourd'hui nous devons choisir est-ce
pour aller vers une société
d'entrepreneurs de soi-même à l'instar
des chauffeurs Hubert esclaves du diktag
du marché ou est-ce pour construire une
société de libre-producteurs associés
qu'appelait d'ailleurs Marx de ses vœux
je vous remercie question importante
pour tous merci Monsieur le 10 de
m'avoir écouté merci cher collègue la
parole est à présent Madame Catherine
brosse de Sailly pour l'Union centriste
et pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
développement exponentiel de la
technologie signifient-il la fin
programmée de l'humanité telle que nous
la connaissons sans être aussi
pessimiste on peut être inquiet des
menaces que l'automatisation croissante
de l'intelligence artificielle
générative et pesée sur l'emploi dans
tous les secteurs sur l'éducation et la
création sur nos modèles de socio et
politique et démocratiques avec de
possibilités en matière de
désinformation de manipulation des
opinions de contrôle des individus si la
presse se fait jour après jour l'écho
des nouvelles prouesses de chat gibity
des pays comme l'Italie et le Canada
l'ont interdit tout comme d'autres ont
banni Tik Tok faut-il une pause sur la
recherche en IA comme l'on demandait
Elon Musk et un millier de scientifiques
peut-être mais ne soyons pas dupe
au-delà des considérations éthiques il y
a pour le dirigeant de Space X et
Twitter dérèglement de compte avec open
a I dans la course effrénée que ce livre
les entreprises pour la captation du
marché faut-il de la régulation et
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics pour
encadrer les futurs applications
assurément je le demande depuis 10 ans
rapport après rapport mesurant la
puissance transformatrice des nouvelles
technologies leurs effets incertains et
potentiellement dangereux sur la mise en
réseau du monde côté régulation après le
rgpd l'Europe est en train de légiférer
avec le DMA le DSA puis en cours
d'adoption aujourd'hui le règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle rapporteur
avec André gatelin et Cyril pelva d'un
avis sur ce texte et auteur d'une
proposition de résolution européenne je
veux en souligner le caractère
précurseur l'Europe étant la première à
se doter d'un cadre juridique maintenant
si son approche par le risque est
pertinente ce texte ne résout pas hélas
les questions éthiques que posent les
algorithmes gourmands de nos données
tout comme les modèles économiques il
est sous tendent je l'ai déjà dit pour
le DSA il faut exiger la transparence
absolue des audits indépendants et avant
toute mise sur le marché d'une
application ou d'un logiciel et tout au
long de leur cycle de vie une évaluation
de possibles effet dangereux incestive
by design en somme je n'ai pas le temps
ici d'évoquer en détail les mesures que
nous avons proposées pourrisser le
règlement à un haut niveau de protection
et palier certaines lacunes nous avons
pris comme la diandre en compte les
risques mais également les progrès
fulgurants rendu possible grâce à l'IA
celle-ci n'est en effet ni positive ni
négative en réalité sa valeur dépend
intrinsèquement de l'usage qui en effet
l'IA c'est aussi pouvoir résoudre par
exemple des questions environnementales
de santé de productivité ces
stratégiques d'où la nécessité pour
l'Europe de soutenir l'innovation or à
défaut de stratégie industrielle ces
dernières années l'Europe c'est
largement fait distancer par les
États-Unis et la Chine qui ont
massivement investi dans la recherche et
le développement de leur propre
entreprise qui dominent aujourd'hui le
monde si l'Europe ne veut pas totalement
disparaître de la carte des technologies
de demain monsieur le ministre elle doit
se réveiller et sortir de les
dépendances dangereuses avec l'inflation
réduction actes les États-Unis vont
investir près de 348 milliards d'euros
on en est loin en Europe il nous faut
pourtant un minimum d'investissement
dans l'IA dans le cloud dans les réseaux
ce qui n'est pas franchement prévu dans
la boussole numérique le plan d'action
2030 de l'Union règlement exigeante donc
formation et information de tous pour ne
pas se laisser dominer par une élite
technologique seul capable de décider de
notre avenir investissement dans la
recherche et soutien assumé à notre
écosystème européen grâce à un bail
européen Act tel est le triptyque pour
lequel je ne cesse de plaider la
maîtrise des technologies les plus
avancées est devenu un enjeu
géopolitique ce n'est donc pas du
protectionnisme c'est la seule manière
de promouvoir un monde basé sur nos
fondamentaux un monde qui n'est ni le
monnaie le modèle business Beauval des
big tech le profit avant la sécurité ni
le modèle du contrôle social par le
Parti communiste chinois l'Europe doit
aussi peser dans les instances mondiales
ou s'élabore les protocoles et standards
peser monsieur le ministre dans
l'élaboration du pacte numérique mondial
proposé par l'ONU pour 2024 ce cadre
d'engagement universel pour lequel j'ai
apporté au nom de l'APF devant l'OIF
doit absolument comprendre des mesures
claires en faveur d'une intelligence
artificielle au service de l'humain
fiable et éthique il y a là un enjeu de
civilisation je vous remercie
merci chers collègues à parler ta
présent à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier au
titre des sénateurs n'appartenant aucun
groupe et pour 3 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre l'avenir la liberté la
souveraineté voici les défis majeurs que
posent l'essor de l'intelligence
artificielle générative à l'heure où 100
millions de personnes ont les yeux rivés
sur leur écran numérique pour admirer
les prouesses aussi extraordinaires qui
effrayante réalisée par le robot chat
gipiti la société semble programmer à
une forme d'obsolescence de ces modes de
production et d'éducation ce ministre
vous avez qualifié de façon assez légère
et définitive l'intelligence
artificielle générative de perroquet
approximatif je crois que vous n'avez
pas pris la mesure de la révolution en
cours les balbutiements quand nous
lançons que balbutiements de cette
technologie dépasse déjà toutes les
performances et des outils que nous
connaissions jusqu'ici les équilibres
économiques du monde vont être
bouleversés et Google pourraient être
remisés au rang des curiosités du passé
alors que la parole publique et les
fonctions électives sont plus que jamais
remises en question dans notre pays le
peuple va chercher les réponses à ces
questions auprès d'algorithmes
pré-entraîné dans la capacité côté
stupéfiante à singer l'intelligence
humaine crée les conditions d'une
dystopie nouvelle les craintes mais
aussi les opportunités que nous en
trouvons avec une telle technologie ne
font que rappeler l'intrusion du
numérique dans nos vies depuis de
nombreuses années nous assistons à la
généralisation de l'ubérisation au
domaine de la pensée cela pose la
question de la liberté et du rapport à
la réalité créer dans la Silicon Valley
c'était ces technologies diffusent un
conformisme idéologique fidèle
progressisme de ces concepteurs et aux
références anglo-saxon c'est donc
l'esprit critique et notre souveraineté
qui sont menacées l'intelligence
artificielle générative représente aussi
une opportunité pour développer le
secteur de la santé et refonder
l'éducation nationale en un système
d'instructions tourné vers l'innovation
à l'ingénierie le monde accélère il
faudrait vous mettre ou remettre
monsieur le ministre en marche aussi
qu'avez-vous prévu pour promouvoir le
développement des entreprises françaises
dans ce domaine et réfléchir aux limites
éthiques que nous devons mettre en place
pour empêcher effondrement de notre pays
et assurer notre compétitivité
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à présent au président
Jean-Claude Riquier pour le groupe RDSE
bien sûr et pour 5 minutes
le président monsieur le ministre mais
chers collègues de services
[Musique]
artificielle à franchise étape
imaginable il y a encore quelques années
une évolution qui quitte à la fois
intérêt et inquiétude
intérêt car il y a des générative celle
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui et la
nouvelle révolution industrielle
porteuse d'innovation à venir temps pour
les biens que pour les services crainte
car son mode de fonctionnement est à
prendre et de prendre ses propres
décisions indépendamment de l'homme dit
comme cela cela peut faire peur allez
faire force de progrès dans quel univers
l'amour basculer celui d'ados le
meilleur des mondes dans lequel
technologie et humanité vont finir par
se fondre nous ne sommes pas là
malheureusement
mais n'attendons pas que certains des
enjeux d'intelligence artificielle soit
hors de contrôle au moment où je ne
pense pas que la question soit encore
celle de savoir si cette technologie est
ou pas elle est déjà à l'oeuvre et les
investissements financiers s'engouffre
avec allégresse par conséquent nous
lançons plutôt à savoir comment
l'encadrer afin de ne pas la subir
l'éthique ayant des premiers enjeux de
l'iaggérative par exemple doit-on
permettre à ces usages pour des
prescriptions médicales des fonctions
d'encadrement du travail ou pour des
programmes de surveillance ces derniers
points nous conduit à suivre la
protection des données personnelles tout
d'abord on doit se réjouir que deux
plaintes étaient récemment déposés en
France auprès de la CNIL par deux
spécialistes de la protection des
données personnelles enfin ensuite
faisons confiance à l'Union européenne
et qui travaille aussi sur ce sujet à
travers l'artificiel intelligente
bienvenue on sait que la mise en place
d'un cadre réglementaire va prendre du
temps face à des technologies dans le
caractère exponentiel est quasi
intrinsèque l'Italie a pu interdisation
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre sur le
principe du moratoire
une autre échelle que celle des pays on
observe également que les institutions
se mobilisent je passe par exemple à
l'interdiction faite par Sciences Po
d'utiliser le robot comme conversion
d'openi en dehors de l'encadrement
pédagogique car en effet une des grandes
craintes de cette technologie et celle
de la police selon des cerveaux dans la
mesure où il y a un générative
inviterait la paresse de l'esprit
critique et dès l'effort de construction
intellectuelle une vaste réception au
sein de l'éducation nationale pourrait
permettre la circonscrire l'usage au
moins durant le stand scolaire il faut
aller faire rapidement s'intéresser à
cet enjeu
le RDSE attaché à l'esprit des Lumières
souhaite que la question des sources
soit également bien appréhendée à la
lumière cette technologie qui peut
alimenter contre vérité et mauvaise
information dans nos sociétés
démocratiques le rapport la vérité est
essentiel on le sait ils doivent
absolument être maîtrisés ce qui est
compliqué avec les outils génératif dont
on ne connaît pas le cheminement de la
confrontation des sources
enfin je n'oublie pas il y a peut-elle
être une réponse à la pénurie de
compétences dans certains secteurs ou au
contraire la terrible promesse
destructions d'emplois les avis
d'experts sont partagés près de 46%
étage administratif 44% des emplois
juridiques seraient susceptibles d'être
automatisés dans une étude affirme que
le développement de l'IA créent des
nouveaux métiers en compensation ne
serait-ce que pour accompagner son
développement et ses impacts offrant la
question de savoir comment partager
équitablement les gains de productivité
qui que peut apporter cette positif
innovation à la société une nouvelle
relation du travail une semaine de 4
jours par exemple il faut en tout cas se
préparer cette évolution des emplois le
plus important étant d'éviter la
précarisation comme on a pu le voir avec
leur ubérisation dans certains secteurs
aussi le semis qui revient à puissance
publique de s'engager fermement sur ce
chantier afin de rappeler que tout n'est
pas permis avec lia et que sa vocation
peut-être de supprimer des tâches et non
des métiers en attendant mon groupe ne
souhaite pas verser dans la technophobie
sur réserve que l'humanisme reste la
valeur centrale du progrès
la parole est à présent à Monsieur Cyril
pelleva pour le groupe des Républicains
il dispose de 7 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis
quelques mois les intelligences
artificielles sont au centre de
l'actualité qu'il s'agisse des logiciels
conversationnels tels que 4G piti ou
Élisa de modèles de génération d'images
et de vidéos ou encore d'autant encodeur
pas une semaine de passe sans que ne
soit à la Une les prouesses de ces
nouvelles technologies pouvant produire
des contenus de manière autonome
suscitant tour à tour admiration et
inquiétude
en réalité la très probable révolution
industrielle que représente les
intelligences artificielles c'est amorcé
depuis plusieurs années déjà nous en
utilisons chaque jour sans le savoir au
fil des mises à jour et de la collecte
toujours plus massive de données elle ne
cesse de se perfectionner si elle
partage des similitudes avec les
intelligences artificielles plus
traditionnelles les intelligences
artificielles génératives ont
comparativement des spécificités
notamment en matière d'éthique de
désinformation de protection des données
ou encore de productivité et d'impact
sur les emplois et bien que les
désaméliorations soient encore
nécessaires pour qu'elles soient
utilisables à un niveau industriel de
nombreuses études montrent que leur
éventuelle généralisation aura des
impacts d'une ampleur inédite depuis
l'arrivée de l'ordinateur ainsi une
étude menée par open I open Church et
l'Université de Pessac Pennsylvanie
avance que 80% de la main d'oeuvre
américaine pourrait voir au moins 10% de
ces tâches réalisées par une
intelligence artificielle générative
pour 19% des travailleurs 50% de leur
tâches pourrait être prise en charge par
ces nouvelles technologies en
particulier dans les domaines des
services administratifs et juridiques du
management des services financiers du
marketing de la communication ou encore
du graphisme et de la conception
d'après une autre étude de la banque
Goldman Sachs ce sont 300 millions
d'emplois qui pourraient à terme être
menacés mais la productivité au travail
pourrait progresser de 1,5 points chaque
année pendant 10 ans tandis que la
hausse annuelle du PIB mondial pour
atteindre les 7% contre 2,9% prévu pour
2023 par le FMI
sans qu'il puisse être affirmé que
certains métiers disparaîtront
inévitablement puisqu’un de productivité
n'entraîne pas nécessairement à
disparaître d'un emploi il est certain
que le marché du travail sera bouleversé
de même de nouveaux métiers apparaîtront
et compenseront probablement le nombre
de postes supprimés ainsi une étude du
Forum économique mondial estime que 87
millions d'emplois seront remplacés par
intelligence artificielle et met en
exerbes qu'il permettront en revanche la
création de 80 15 millions d'emplois
bien sûr il ne s'agit à ce stade que de
prévisions et les impacts sur les
marchés du travail devront de toute
évidence est suivi de près afin que nous
puissions nous adapter à des effets
imprévus
en août pour profiter pleinement des
externalités positives de l'intelligence
artificielle générative il ne faut pas
que la France loupe le coche en matière
d'innovation comme de formation à ces
nouveaux métiers les géants de la tech
sont déjà dans les starting locks et
malgré l'existence de certaines startups
françaises prometteuses la France est
plus largement l'Europe fait bien pas le
figure face aux compagnies américaines
et chinoises qui investissent des
milliards de dollars dans cette
technologie ma première question de
féministe porte donc sur les moyens que
le gouvernement compte mette en œuvre
pour d'une part soutenir l'innovation
des entreprises françaises dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
et d'autre part faut pas favoriser la
formation de ces métiers d'avenir ainsi
que la reconversion pour les
travailleurs dont l'emploi pourrait
devenir obsolète
abordons désormais des aspects de
l'intelligence artificielle générative
qui sont autrement moins réjouissants
que la hausse de la productivité que la
création de nouveaux emplois il apparaît
en effet que des usages malveillants de
ce type d'intelligence artificielle
ainsi que des erreurs de l'intelligence
artificielle elle-même peuvent avoir des
conséquences dramatiques sur les
libertés fondamentales dont le droit à
la protection des données personnelles
les expériences ces dernières semaines
voire dernières années nous prouvent que
ces dangers sont réels non respect du
rgpd par tchat dépiti un jeune homme
poussé au suicide par le chat robot
Élisée en Belgique images devenue virale
du président de la République et du pape
créé par l'intelligence artificielle
deep fake de personnalité publique
logiciel de recrutement d'Amazon
discriminatoire discriminatoire envers
les femmes ou encore le scandale des
allocations familiales aux Pays-Bas du
hangorithme d'auto-apprentissage qui
cibla les minorités et les accusés à
tort de fraude et les exemples sont
nombreux et se multiplient
qu'il s'agisse de la non conformité du
logiciel avec la réglementation d'erreur
faites par l'intelligence artificielle
ou d'usage sciemment malveillants par
des huîtres par des utilisateurs il est
nécessaire de trouver des solutions et
de légiférer pour éviter ces effets de
bord sans pour autant interdire les
intelligences artificielle génératives
il s'agirait en effet d'une grave erreur
d'un point de vue économique qui ferait
perdre à la France encore plus de temps
dans la course effrénée à l'innovation
en la matière les entreprises
développantes l'intelligence
artificielle sont elles-mêmes en faveur
de l'élaboration d'une réglementation
comme la récemment fait savoir openahi
car ce n'est qu'avec un cadre clair
établissant une sécurité juridique que
les potentialités économiques et
sociétales de l'intelligence
artificielle pourront pleinement se
mettre en place
le rgpd apporte un premier échelon de
réponse en matière de protection des
données utilisées par les intelligences
artificielles mais ce n'est pas
suffisant pour éviter l'ensemble des
potentiels externalités négatives et
peut parfois être contre-productif en
matière d'innovation notamment car ce
n'est qu'en traitant certains données
personnelles qu'il sera possible pour
les entreprises de lutter contre les
biais de système d'intelligence
artificielle des dérogations rgpd
devront donc nécessairement être prévues
mais encadrés strictement pour pouvoir
se prémunir de tout utilisation
détournée de ces données sensibles
notamment à des fins commerciales
ces dangers réels ou prévisible de
l'intelligence artificielle et cette
inadaptation du rgpd en conduit l'Union
européenne à se saisir de la question
des intelligences artificielles au sens
large par le biais d'une proposition de
règlement avec mes collègues on en a
déjà parlé tout à l'heure André gatolin
Catherine Morin de saillie elles
achchalke nous avons dans le cas des
travaux de la commission des affaires
européennes est chargé d'élaborer une
proposition de résolution européenne et
un rapport relatif à ce règlement
ce dernier est assurément un pas dans la
bonne direction pour sécuriser les
intelligences artificielle mais nous
avons relevé avec les cours rapporteurs
certaines lacunes faute de temps je
m’arrêterai pas sur chacune des d'entre
elles mais je souhaiterais monsieur le
ministre connaître la position du
Gouvernement sur nos propositions et les
points principaux que vous souhaitez
soutenir au conseil sur ce règlement en
août j'insiste sur l'absolu nécessité
pour la France comme pour l'Union
d'engager des discussions avec les pays
non membres au sein des instances de
normalisation internationales pour les
inviter à adopter des réglementations
similaires en effet être les seuls États
imposer des normes aussi ambitieuses va
certes protéger les citoyens européens
mais pourraient nous désavantager d'un
point de vue concurrentiel aussi une
seule ministre pourriez-vous m'indiquer
si des échanges ont déjà été mis en
place avec d'autres pays et notamment
les Etats-Unis et la Chine pour
promouvoir l'élaboration de législation
similaires dans ces états je vous
remercie pour votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Madame Vanina Paoli Gaga pour
les indépendants
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2017
notre groupe Les Indépendants avait
organisé en ces murs un débat sur
l'intelligence artificielle en jeu
économiques et cadre légaux au vu de
l'accélération de ces technologies et
des enjeux y a différents nous avons
jugé opportun de proposer à nouveau ce
thème et je salue le choix collectif et
partager d'évoquer ensemble les défis de
l'intelligence artificielle dite
générative j'ai eu personnellement la
chance d'assister dans mon expérience
professionnelle et dans ma pratique un
Forum mondial sur l'IA à Anjo en Chine
en 2017 avec des mines chercheurs du
monde entier dont yoval Noah Harari que
vous connaissez tous
j'ai cru comprendre de ces propos que la
différence majeure entre l'IA et le
cerveau humain finalement c'était
l'intention qui est le seul la seule
qui l'apanache de ce sol dernier pardon
et je pense que c'est sur cela que nous
devons monsieur le ministre
sur le plan éthique nous concentré
dès 1900 dès 2016 pardon l'OCDE nous
prévenait que 9% des emplois en France
présentaient un risque élevé de
substitution par des robots avec
l'amélioration permanente de l'IA cette
proportion augmentera une vérité annoncé
car ces prévisions pessimistes ne
parlent que des destructions et non pas
des nouvelles créations j'ai un exemple
frappant dans l'Aube mon département
avec une entreprise qui s'appelle
gambarota qui est une entreprise de
logistique familiale qui investit 10
millions d'euros pour
robotiser vialia son outil logistique ça
lui permet d'envisager la création de
plus d'une centaine d'emplois
nous sommes à l'aube d'une vaste
révolution de l'emploi et du rapport au
travail cela vaut particulièrement pour
les jeunes plus que jamais en quête de
sens dans leur vie professionnelle
l'approche binaire ça a été dit par des
collègues précédemment entre
technophiles BA et des tracteurs
outranciers et bien évidemment dépassé
l'immense défi de l'IA invite au
contraire à la nuance et à la précision
dans un univers en perpétuelle mutation
il s'agit à la fois d'anticiper les
grandes évolutions sociétales mais aussi
économiques et politiques qui en
découleront l'importance des progrès
permanents engendrés par l'IA fait écho
à l'ampleur des craintes qu'elle nous
inspire
à ces inquiétudes il nous faut répondre
avec pédagogie pour tirer profit des
perspectives positives ouvertes par
cette technologie
il nous faut répondre avec lucidité
aussi pour anticiper les changements
d'ampleur qui surviendront notamment sur
le marché du travail il nous faut
également répondre à avec fermeté par un
cadre réglementaire solide pour garantir
à nos concitoyens Unia fiable et sur
l'Europe doit développer une approche
éthique des données avec une méthode et
un cadre réglementaire propre cela
implique de s'affranchir de la Chine des
États-Unis qui nous imposent depuis un
certain temps à la fois leur calendrier
et leurs objectifs les gafam conservent
évidemment leur puissance de par les
supports qu'ils ont donné au monde
depuis tant d'années à l'instar de
Microsoft avec tchat GPT l'Europe a
perdu on l'a dit la bataille des données
personnelles
celle des données professionnelles est
en cours les gens y abusent de leur
position dominante nous devons aborder
avec une grande vigilance le recours à
l'IA via les outils
dans nos entreprises les gains de
productivité espérés ne doivent pas
masquer l'aspirateur à donner qu'il
représente la France est également
pénalisée par la fuite de certains de
ses cerveaux alors même que leur
formation a été assuré sur deniers
publics nous finançons en partie notre
propre dépendance
pourtant notre pays dispose à tout
essentiel et d'un viviers d'acteurs
spécialisés selon France digitale
l'écosystème français rassemble plus de
590 startups en IA et plus de 80
laboratoires de recherche sur ce même
sujet qui sont en pôle position à
l'échelon européen on a donc des
compétences monsieur le ministre qui
sont réels et pointus dans certaines
niches c'est notre force et je pense que
nous pouvons également dynamiser ses
forces grâce aux droits nous attendons
beaucoup
de l'artificion l'intelligence acte ce
cadre nouveau doit nous redonner une
longueur d'avance j'en profite pour
saluer la mobilisation de Thierry Breton
notre commissaire européen au Marché
intérieur sous l'impulsion duquel nous
avons en deux ans ce qui est un temps
record bâti une réglementation Ia dont
la précision et la complétude est
inégalée les prochaines années
s'annoncent des sites décisives il n'est
pas question de se laisser distancier
davantage sous peine de rater
définitivement l'opportunité de rester
encore dans la course dès lors monsieur
le ministre comment la France
s'engage-t-elle face à l'enjeu de
positionner positionner pendant l'Europe
en chef de fil tout en garantissant la
sécurité et les droits des utilisateurs
que pensez-vous à cet égard monsieur le
ministre des récentes positions de
l'Italie et pouvez-vous nous indiquer
précisément quel est notre feuille de
route à l'échelle temps nationale
européenne sur ce sujet je vous remercie
solidarité et territoire pour 5 minutes
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous
connaissez mon appétence pour
l'intelligence artificielle j'ai
d'ailleurs moi aussi tenté de rédiger
mon intervention avec chaque GPT mais
j'ai trouvé le résultat décevant mais je
l'avais fait il y a quelques mois en
posant une question d'actualité au
ministre et d'éducation nationale en
utilisant cette épée pour l'alerter sur
la suppression de la technologie en
sixième au collège alors même que cette
matière supprimée était directement liée
aux enjeux du numérique pourtant la
France a pu que jamais besoin d'une
jeunesse ouverte aux sciences et aux
technologies
en tant qu'enseignante je suis
impressionnée par les résultats obtenus
avec l'intelligence artificielle les
perspectives sont de sans limites et
dans des domaines aussi barrés que
l'agriculture la logistique ou la santé
mais en tant que citoyenne les
forfulgurantes ces nouvelles
technologies m'interrogent quel cadre
quel réglementation quelles objectifs
quelles conséquences pour notre société
en tant que parlementaire le travail que
nous devons mener sur ce sujet colossal
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer l'Union
européenne qui examine en ce moment liée
à acte un projet de règlement pour
encadrer l'usage et la commercialisation
des intelligences artificielles je
regarde aussi avec intérêt la décision
de l'Italie qui vient de bloquer chaque
GPT pour respecter la législation sur
les données personnelles
l'interdiction n'est probablement
probablement pas la bonne solution mais
elle doit nous interroger sur les
limites de cet outil
car oui malgré la fascination que
suscite de telles innovations
technologiques nous devons garder les
pieds sur terre pour légiférer dans
l'intérêt général
il y a 10 ans rappelez-vous nous avions
de grands espoirs pour les assistants
numériques comme Siri ou Alexa il a
encore quelques mois nous parlions des
crypto monnaie avec des étoiles dans les
yeux pourtant ces innovations n'ont fait
que créer de nouveaux besoins sans
apporter de solutions concrètes même
avec la révolution informatique Internet
les gains de productivité sont en baisse
depuis 30 ans si certains prophètes
prédisent de formidables gains de
productivité et voit l'intelligence
artificielle comme une poule aux œufs
d'or la réalité sera certainement tout à
fait autre
nous devons également nous interroger
sur les conséquences sociales d'un
développement massif de l'intelligence
artificielle
dans un récent scénario Goldman sach
estime que 300 millions d'emplois seront
menacés par l'essor de l'intelligence
artificielle
s'il ne sert à rien de crier au loup
nous ne pouvons ignorer cette alerte
d'autant qu'une partie des emplois créés
par ces nouvelles technologies sont un
gras et mal payées derrière les
ingénieurs il y a les petites mains de
l'intelligence artificielle des Kenyans
payer un à deux douleurs par jour ont
été employés par cette GPT pour repérer
les contenus toxiques avec un rythme de
travail soutenu et des conditions de
travail déplorables
si une intelligence artificielle ne
remplace pas nos emplois elle pourrait
être à l'origine une nouvelle
dégradation du travail
enfin le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui ou bien un aspect
fondamental qui n'est plus acceptable
d'ignorer au 21e siècle je parle bien
sûr de l'impact environnemental et
climatique de l'intelligence
artificielle
le numérique représente déjà 4% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde et l'intelligence artificielle
n'échappe pas à cette règle
entraîner un modèle tel que celui chaque
GPT pendant 4 à 7 jours et mettrai
autant que l'être humain pendant 57 ans
une estimation qui progresse à mesure
que les modèles d'intelligence
artificielle se perfectionnent et
accumule des connaissances
derrière la chimère bien numérique
durable dans les applications feraient
disparaître par magie les risques
environnementaux il y a la réalité des
chiffres ainsi c'est les possibilités
permissent par l'intelligence
artificielle nous font rêver nous devons
être pleinement conscient des impacts
économiques sociaux et environnementaux
de cette technologie
l'intelligence artificielle est là elle
fait déjà partie de nos vies il n'est
donc pas question de l'interdire ou de
la réserver à une élite mais nous devons
la réguler et la conditionner à sa
plus-value sociale et environnementale
comme le souligner le penseur Jacques et
lul la technique n'est pas neutre mais
elle n'est ni bonne ni mauvaise elle est
ambivalente je vous remercie merci chers
collègues
Sylvie Robert pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2018 le
Grand Palais organisé une exposition
artiste et robot en 2019 c'était autour
du barbecane Center à Londres de
présenter au public une exposition
interactive amor van human à la
curiosité et l'enthousiasme suscité par
l'arrivée de ces nouvelles technologies
d'abord perçu comme récréative et utile
en termes de productivité ont succédé
aujourd'hui inquiétudes méfiance et
surtout questionnement alors nous ne
devons pas être dupe des intentions
cachées de l'entrepreneur qui a
orchestré la tribune tonitruante
kossignée par fût de mille experts du
secteur de l'IA elle a eu une vertu
celle de frapper les esprits et
notamment en parlant de moratoire mais
vraiment il faut prendre du recul et
mesurer les conséquences réguler et
mettre en place les garde-fous cela
devient nécessaire c'est d'ailleurs le
sens de la de la décision de la CNIL
italienne qui a bloqué temporairement
principaux premièrement aucun mécanisme
de vérification de l'âge des mineurs
n'est prévu alors que le droit et la
protection des mineurs en ligne est un
sujet politique majeur et deuxièmement
tchadipiti a récolté indument les
données personnelles des utilisateurs
italiens en conséquence la protection
des données personnelles et le respect
de la vie privée des utilisateurs dit
Leia génératif sont des enjeux
fondamentaux au cœur de la régulation et
de leur contrôle par les cnils des
différents états la difficulté de cette
régulation comme en matière numérique de
manière générale procède des usages qui
se développent beaucoup plus vite que la
réglementation ainsi tchadji pitty est
principalement apparu dans le débat
public suite à son emploi par les
étudiants pour la rédaction de divers
travaux à cet égard en matière éducative
liagénérative pose plusieurs
problématiques sérieuses en premier lieu
très souvent elle est configurée à
partir de la technique dite du machine
learning autrement dit elle est nourrie
de contenu dont la fiabilité et la
véracité peuvent être sujets à voire
complètement fantaisiste d'autre part
ces contenus pouvant être orientés lia
peut apporter des réponses comportant
des biais importants notamment sociaux
ratio et de gens ce qui aurait un impact
dramatique dans la formation et la
représentation des jeunes enfin en
l'état lia générative en contradiction
totale avec deux fondements et
essentiels de l'instruction reposer sur
des faits et non des noms de fausses
informations et favoriser l'acquisition
d'aptitudes et de compétences par
l'expérience dans le domaine de
l'éducation son encadrement s'avère donc
primordial et recourir à la médiation un
préalable minimal en août l'un des
impacts les plus visibles de
liagénérative à très au secteur culturel
et singulièrement à la définition de
l'acte de création et la protection du
droit d'auteur sur ce point je tiens
affirmer une position claire et sans
ambiguïté le cadre juridique notamment
européen n'est ni adapté ni suffisant il
est indispensable que l'artificiel
intelligence acte en cours de discussion
au Parlement européen mais percuté de
plein fouet par l'émer
contiennent des dispositions qui
protègent les artistes auteurs au regard
de la révolution que constitue cesia il
n'est pas possible d'en rester une
simple possibilité d'octaoat pour les
titulaires des ayants droits qui ne
souhaitent pas que leurs œuvres
alimentent ces machines le statu quo est
synonyme de déséquilibre et renoncement
à l'effectivité du droit d'auteur
néanmoins il est impératif de protection
renforcer des créateurs qui concernent
l'ensemble des champs culturels n'épuise
aucunement la réflexion sur l'impact
culturel de l'IA à ce titre le CSPLA
avait commis un rapport en 2020 sur
l'intelligence artificielle et la
culture et soulevait deux questions
majeures quel statut pour les créations
réalisées à partir du nia et pour les
personnes qui en sont à l'origine et
surtout existe-t-il réellement un
processus créatif à l'oeuvre lorsque
l'IA est utilisé ainsi pour conclure lia
génératif bouscule et interroge jusqu'à
notre conception même de l'acte de
création bien qu'elle soit encore assez
prémices je pense que nous avons
collectivement l'intuition et la
conviction qu'il faut impérativement
l'encadrer pour qu'elle soit porteuse du
meilleur et non du pire à nous de lui
donner du sens je vous remercie
merci
la part est ensuite à Monsieur
Pierre-Antoine Lévy
Union centriste
et également pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
avec l'émergence de l'intelligence
artificielle dans nos vies le monde va
vivre une quatrième révolution
industrielle il habite d'ailleurs déjà
avec l'apparition ces dernières semaines
d'outils conversationsnels ou de
générations d'image particulièrement
innovants et bluffant d'efficacité nous
aurions pu tous d'ailleurs demander à
tchat djibiti 4 de préparer ce discours
ceux qui auraient fait gagner du temps
mais au-delà du temps gagné je pense que
nous serions tous ou presque retrouver
avec le même discours ce qui aurait
rendu ce débat d'actualité fort ennuyeux
face aux capacités extrêmement
impressionnantes de l'intelligence
artificielle nous voyons apparaître
beaucoup d'inquiétudes et cela
illégitime est-ce que l'humain va se
faire dépoussiérer de son travail au fur
et à mesure du développement de
l'intelligence artificielle
allons-nous de moins en moins penser
allons-nous vers un monde où nous ne
serions plus mettre de nos habits et de
nos destins
monsieur le ministre déclariez il y a
quelques semaines à propos de tiadibetti
qu'il était un perroquet approximatif
peut-être habiez-vous testé la version 3
car je peux vous assurer que de
nombreuses réponses notamment dans la
version 4 était tenté de bon sens de
réflexion et de précision
je n'ose pas imaginer ce que donnera la
version 5 de Chady qui est annoncé pour
décembre et qui d'après openaïs sont
développeur serait au niveau de
l'intelligence humaine
il y a donc de quoi avoir peur que vont
devenir ces milliers d'emplois dans les
secteurs pouvant être remplacés
efficacement par les intelligences
artificielles comment le nom apprendre
maintenant que l'intelligence
artificielle est censée savoir faire à
peu près tout ce qui demande la
réflexion
ces crèmes sont réelles mais la nuancée
car la perception que nous avons de
l'intelligence artificielle varie en
fonction des pays ces chiffres viennent
à sondage international réalisé par x 62
2022 en Chine 79% des personnes sont des
considèrent que l'intelligence
artificielle est plus bénéfique que
négative
71% en Inde et 65% Malaisie et en France
seulement
31%. sa peine mieux chez nos voisins
européens ces symptomatiques de notre
rapport à l'innovation et aux nouvelles
technologies
cela me fait penser d'ailleurs faire la
phrase de la patron du Medef italien
Emma marsigaglia lorsqu'il y a une
innovation les Américains en font
commerce les Chinois la copie et nous
européens nous en faisons le règlement
effectivement le commissaire européen
Thierry Breton a annoncé avec une grande
fierté comme moins de 2 ans l'Union
européenne aura créé une réglementation
pour encadrer les intelligences
artificielles je vous avoue que j'aurais
quand même préféré qu'il annonce le
lancement d'un grand projet de création
d'un champion européenne de Ligue 1
nous pouvons faire tous les règlements
toutes les lois cette nouvelle
révolution industrielle est lancée et ne
pourra pas être arrêtée nous avons le
choix de nous en servir comme un
merveilleux outils au service de la
médecine de l'éducation notamment dans
le monde du travail des gains de
productivité vont pouvoir être énorme ne
soyons pas la traîne accompagnant le
mouvement apprenons à nos jeunes à
utiliser de façon intelligente pour qu'à
la place de vulgaire plagiat ils
utilisent l'intelligence artificielle
comme un assistant d'éducation d'un
outil au service du savoir
monsieur le ministre je salue vous
propose un priori d'interdire
l'utilisation de churchibity comme l'ont
fait temporairement nos voisins italiens
qui d'ailleurs contourné par
l'utilisation de VPN
je salue aussi les travaux colossaux de
nos chercheurs à Paris Saclay notamment
sur Bloom l'outil français dire Google
qui a lancé sa propre intelligence
artificielle pour concurrencer ou pénali
a reconnu que tchadjibiti était une
Ferrari alors que la sienne était au
mieux une Honda civique améliorée ma
crainte est donc la suivante la déjà
pris trop de retard sur les entreprises
américaines alors Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur le fait
que la France sera bien au rendez-vous
de cette quatrième révolution
industrielle je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
et à présent la discussion générale est
conclue par notre collègue Jean-Jacques
malouzi pour les républicains
et pour 7 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
depuis quelques mois les intelligences
artificielles génératives influence
notre quotidien et monopolyse de
l'espace médiatique chaque GPT lança au
milieu autant de logiciels d'y engagés
dans une course frénétique pour devenir
la référence en la matière
qu'est-ce que l'intelligence
artificielle générative
viager est un sous domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle qui crée des
contenus tels que des textes des images
des vidéos des programmes informatiques
c'est alliéger que l'on doit notamment
les photos truquées du pape François
doudoune blanche ou de l'ancien
président Donald Trump menotté et qui
ont beaucoup circulé
moins de mois après son lancement en
janvier 2023 chaque GPT développé par
l'entreprise californienne open high
dépassait les 100 millions
d'utilisateurs ce qui ont fait
l'application et on tue la croissance la
plus rapide jusqu'à ce jour la nouvelle
version GPT 4 dévoilé mi mars avec des
incroyables améliorations amènent à
poser à se poser la grande question
est-ce que lia remplacera les humains
par les machines
d'intelligence artificielle est déjà en
train de changer le monde du travail
les machines sont capables d'apprendre
et de s'adapter à des tâches qui étaient
auparavant réservées aux humains la
question des conséquences sur l'emploi
se pose comme à chaque grande révolution
technologique déclenchant après
attention et crispation ainsi dans les
salles de rédaction des journaux la
question se posera concernant les
journalistes et illustrateurs aura-t-on
encore besoin de dans les cabinets
d'avocats ou de conseils on se demandera
s'il est encore nécessaire d'avoir des
juristes et des consultants open high a
ainsi fait passer le concours du
barbouro américain à chaque GPT qui a
été Bréal brillamment reçu
les experts de Goldman sat estime que
les IA génératives pourraient supprimer
jusqu'à 300 millions d'emplois dans le
monde
les grandes immolations dans l'histoire
ont souvent eu des conséquences sur les
emplois le cabinet américain mckenze
souligne que le fossé risque de se
creuser entre les travailleurs et les
pays les principaux pays qui tireront
partie de l'IA seront sans doute des
États-Unis et la Chine la France le
Royaume-Uni ou la Corée du Sud serait
toutefois relativement bien positionné
d'un point de vue économique en général
Léa générative peut avoir des impacts
considérables ce sont les économistes de
Goldman Sachs l'adoption généralité de
l'IA pourrait accroître la productivité
et augmenter le PIB mondial de 7% par an
lesag nous l'avons vu peut être utilisé
notamment pour créer des contenus à
grandes écoles en temps record ou bien à
créer des produits et des services
personnalisés toutefois l'utilisation de
l'IAG dans les affaires doit être
éthique responsable afin de minimiser
des impacts négatifs potentiels des fake
news propagées grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle des images truquées de
fausses révélations peut avoir un impact
très important sur les cours des bourses
mondiales et les faire chuter d'un point
de vue social ou sociétal et agénérative
peut également avoir des impacts
positifs comme négatifs elle peut
contribuer à la création des contenus
artistiques et culturels innovants mais
peut aussi perdre de faux contenu semer
la désinformation
peut aussi être utilisé pour créer des
discours de haine du cyber-harcèlement
et favoriser la violence des campagnes
mensongères la Commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés commence
à s'intéresser au cas de chaque gptt
elle a défini un plan d'action plaidant
pour une claire clarification du cadre
légal d'un point de vue politique en fin
Liège peut avoir des impacts importants
elle peut aider à la prise de décision
mais elle peut aussi véhiculer des
idéologies de façon insidieuse dans de
très nombreux domaines comme la santé
l'environnement elle peut également être
utilisée pour surveiller les citoyens le
Parlement européen a créé une commission
sur l'intelligence artificielle à l'ère
numérique la Commission a initié en
avril 2021 un règlement sur l'IA en
cours d'examen au Parlement européen
l'exécutif européen n'a pas fermé la
porte à l'usage dia utilisant la
biométrie elle a gardé la possibilité
d'utiliser la reconnaissance faciale a
posturer sous contrôle judiciaire en
France le ministère des Sports affirmé
que le recours à la reconnaissance
faciale était exclue par le projet de
loi relatif à l'organisation des Jeux de
2024 seul seront utilisés des caméras
usant d'algorithmes intelligents
l'agence de police européenne rôle à de
son côté averti que les criminels
étaient prêts à tirer parti de
intelligence artificielle en sommeil
peut avoir un impact très important sur
la politique en offrant de nouvelles
opportunités toutefois il est nécessaire
de veiller à ce qu'elle soit utilisée
dans des limites clairement établies et
valider légalement au plan international
la Chine est très en avance et des plats
de gros moyens une compétition acharnée
et prévisible en Russie le président
Poutine estimait dès 2017 que quiconque
deviendra le leader dans ce domaine
deviendra le dirigeant du monde et le
long musk co-fondateur d'Open high avec
ça maintenant inventeur de chatte GPT a
réclamé une pause de 6 mois dans la
recherche en évoquant des risques
majeurs pour l'humanité le 4 avril le
président américain jobidène a évoqué
les risques de l'intelligence
artificielle il a demandé au congrès de
fixer des limites strictes aux données
personnelles collectées et d'interdire
la publicité visant cibler visant les
enfants en tant que pays leader en
matière de technologie et de recherche
la France a un rôle important à jouer
elle devrait continuer à soutenir la
recherche tout en élaborant une
réglementation adaptée et investir dans
la formation tout en assurant la
sécurité et la protection des droits des
individus monsieur le ministre compte
tenu de toutes ces données sur l'IAG
estimez-vous que la France a la capacité
d'être suffisamment réactive ou à tel
prix du retard et comment va-t-on
rattraper celui-ci et avec quel moyen
monsieur le ministre vous avez pu
maintenant la parole va porter votre
contribution à se débat d'actualité
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs j'ai suivi
l'exemple de Monique de Marco et
Pierre-Antoine Lévy en ne faisant pas
appel à chat GPT pour répondre à vos
interventions la preuve papier crayon
pourquoi
et bien parce que pour bien agir pour
bien légiférer il faut bien comprendre
et dire ce que l'intelligence
artificielle générative le sujet de
notre débat dire ce qu'elle est mais
aussi dire ce qu'elle n'est pas c'est
que ce qu'elle n'est pas ou ce qu'elle
ne devrait pas être c'est une nouvelle
pythique qui rendrait des des oracles
sur tous les sujets du monde ce qu'elle
n'est pas c'est une intelligence
créatrice puisqu'elle est une
intelligence générative
c'est une intelligence créative plutôt
qu'une intelligence générative une
intelligence qui réagence des contenus
préexistants sans connaissance
structurée du monde ce qui fait d'elle
un perroquet stochastique ce qui en
langage commun équivaut un perroquet
approximatif dans des plaises à Stéphane
Ravier qui restant dans le registre
animalier évoqué tout à l'heure la
capacité de chaque GPT à saint-ger les
comportements humains mais s'il y a une
différence entre l'intelligence humaine
et l'intelligence artificielle
générative s'il fallait en conserver une
seule c'est c'est Vanina paoligans qui
l’évoquait tout à l'heure cette
différence d'ailleurs était soulevée il
y a quatre siècles par Blaise Pascal
inventeur si l'on peut dire de la
première machine d'intelligence
artificielle la Pascaline cette
différence c'est l'intention c'est la
capacité de volonté et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs s'agissant de la
réponse que nous entendons apporter à
l'irruption des systèmes type du type de
chat GPT que vous avez abandonné
abondamment cité ce sont des réponses
volontaristes des réponses volontarisme
et qui
repose sur une position équilibrée comme
certains d'entre vous leur rappeler je
pense aux propos de Christian Redon
sarrazzi tout à l'heure au Monique de
Marco la technologie en elle-même n'est
ni poison ni remède et nous ne sommes
donc ni technolattre ni technophobe nous
considérons que la technologie doit être
placée au service de l'homme alors oui
l'arrivée très rapide de cette
technologie suscite des questions qui
n'ont pas encore trouvé toute leur
réponse Cyril pelva Jean-Jacques Panunzi
entre autres ont évoqué les effets
ambigus que l'on peut attendre de cette
technologie sur le marché du tri du
travail qui certes va soulager un
certain nombre de travailleurs de tâches
pénibles répétitives fastidieuses mais
qui va aussi bousculer un certain nombre
de professions et face à cela il nous
faut évidemment donner tous les moyens à
nos concitoyens de pouvoir se saisir de
ces outils pour qu'ils puissent en
bénéficier s'assurer que l'entrée ou
l'adoption de ces technologies se fasse
dans la justice sociale et de la même
manière que nous ne
comptons pas sur la technologie pour
nous pour dicter le cours des choses
c'est c'est notre volonté que de dicter
le cours des choses à la technologie la
technologie et en particulier
l'intelligence artificielle générative
n'exclut pas les communs numériques
Pascal salvadelli évoquait tout à
l'heure puisque avant chaque GPT est né
un modèle Open Source collaboratif en
français notamment qui est le modèle
Bloom qui a pu être conçu grâce au
soutien du supercalculateur Janzé alors
faut-il une pause faut-il faire un
moratoire comme Catherine Morin de
saillie la dit tout à l'heure la
question mérite d'être posée la réponse
qui a été apportée notamment par les
signataires de la pétition récente est
mauvaise et à bien des égards il nous
faut accélérer car la France dispose de
tous les atouts pour maîtriser ces
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
générative et nous n'avons pas nous
n'allons pas commencé aujourd'hui
puisqu'il y a 5 ans le président de la
République a souhaité lancer une
stratégie nationale pour l'intelligence
artificielle dotée de 1 milliard et demi
d'euros qui a déjà pu faire émerger des
instituts interdisciplinaires pour
l'intelligence artificielle les trois Ia
à Nice à Toulouse à Grenoble et à Paris
qui ont permis de d'établir 190 chars de
recherche pour intelligence artificielle
de multiplier par deux le nombre de
diplômés en intelligence artificielle
d'avoir 500 doctorants supplémentaires
cette stratégie est complétée par une
stratégie d'accélération pour
l'intelligence artificielle inscrite au
cœur de France 2030 ce qui répondra aux
questions de Cyril pelva de Jean-Jacques
palmzi ou de Pierre-Antoine Lévis sur
les ambitions que nous entendons suivre
ensuite faut-il ou non réguler
évidemment qu'il faut le faire je
reviendrai pas sur le règlement pour
l'intelligence artificielle qui vise
vous permettre à nos concitoyens de
faire toujours la différence entre
l'humain et la machine en imposant des
obligations de transparence et puis qui
imposent dans ce domaine là un régime de
reste responsabilité pour les
concepteurs des systèmes d'intelligence
artificielle en fonction des risques
associés aux usages de ces systèmes pour
certains usages
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle sera proscrit pour d'autres
elle sera encadrée par des obligations
transparence et d'audit au préalable à
la mise sur le marché de ce type de
solution et pour d'autres elle sera
utilisable elle sera mobilisable plus
librement est-ce que ce règlement pour
l'intelligence artificielle couvre tous
les sujets non et certains d'entre eux
ont été cités par les orateurs à la
tribune je pense à l'empreinte carbone
si tu es par Sylvie Robert je pense à la
normalisation avec les États-Unis
notamment et la Chine cité partielle
pellera et Catherine Morin de Saïd des
discussions en d'ores et déjà lieu avec
les États-Unis au sein du TTC mais il
faut qu'elle puisse poursuivre je pense
à l'exploitation des travailleurs des
pays du Sud évoqués par Monique de Marco
et Pascal salvol d'Elli une question sur
laquelle il faudra être vigilant la
question des droits d'auteur évoquée par
Sylvie Robert et Jean-Claude Riquier qui
n'est à ce jour pas traité et qui est à
laquelle il faudra bien apporter une
réponse et enfin celle de la protection
des données personnelles ce ce problème
même qu'évoque l'acné l'italienne pour
interdire
4G pété sur le sol italien les modèles
d'intelligence artificielle sont
entraînés sur des jeux de données et en
particulier des jeux qui sont assemblés
sur internet internet qui contient des
données personnelles qui ont été
collectées avec un consentement qui à
l'époque n'était pas prévu pour venir
alimenter des jeux d'entraînement il va
donc nous falloir réconcilier la
réglementation que nous construisons
pour l'intelligence artificielle avec
celle que nous avons construite et dont
nous sommes très fiers pour la
protection des données personnelles
mesdames et messieurs et sénateurs je
vous remercie beaucoup du temps que vous
avez consacré à ces débats certaines des
préoccupations qui vous qui sont les
vôtres sont d'ores et déjà traités par
la réglementation sur laquelle nous
avançons et par le plan d'investissement
souhaité par le Président de la
République d'autres nourriront un an pas
douter les travaux du Sénat dans les
mois et les années à venir
merci monsieur le ministre
ceci conclut donc le débat d'actualité
que nous avions organisé je vais
suspendre la séance pour quelques
instants en sorte de permettre à chacun
de s'installer et notamment la ministre
prévu pour le prochain point l'ordre du
jour la séance est suspendue